queen elizabeth ii a constitutional
constant who saw fourteen prime
ministers come and go
from churchill to cameron
macmillan to may
thatcher to truss
anointing her 15th pm just two days
before she died devotion to duty to the
very end
a procession into parliament to lead
hours of tributes mps gathered to mark
the passing of a monarch mourned by
millions deeply missed in this place the
mother of all parliaments
the new prime minister leading the
tribute
i have personally greatly valued her
wise advice
it was just three days ago at balmoral
that she invited me to form a government
and become her 15th prime minister
again she generously shared with me her
deep experience of government even in
those last days
mp sharing personal and professional
accounts of the queen who touched not
just their lives but the life of nations
around the world queen elizabeth created
a special personal relationship with us
all
that relationship was built on the
attributes
that defined her reign
her total commitment to service and duty
her deep devotion to the country the
commonwealth
and the people she loved
this former prime minister pained
she helped to comfort
and guide us
as well as the nation because
she had the patience and the sense of
history
to see that troubles come and go
and the disasters are seldom as bad
as they seem
and it was that indomitability
that humor
that work ethic and that sense of
history which together made her
elizabeth the great a sentiment shared
by another former prime minister who
knew the queen so well
i am sometimes asked among all the world
leaders i met
who was the most impressive
and i have no hesitation in sale
but from all the heads of state and
government the most impressive person i
met was her late majesty queen elizabeth
ii
admiration and fond remembrance it was
all mixed in
with deep grief former foreign secretary
margaret beckett one of the few mps to
remember the queen's coronation nearly
overwhelmed
she was a remarkable person a remarkable
monarch
and we are the poorer for her going
[Music]
this prime minister spent 10 years by
her side and led the nation through the
loss of princess diana if princess diana
as you described was the people's
princess what was queen elizabeth
queen elizabeth was
she was armonic
but she was in a center matriarch uh the
mother of our nation i mean she
represented that to people
her fast prime minister born a century
before her last the most remarkable
reign for the most remarkable of
monarchs her wise counsel will be deeply
missed bethrigby sky news westminster